okay I think folks are going to like
this follow up on the Gavin McInnes
situation so Gavin McInnes is formerly
one of the or he is one of the founders
of vice he hasn't been involved with
vice for a very long time he was one of
the cofounders of the proud boys
although I am told he has since
distanced himself from that extremist
group and in any case the newest thing
he's doing is he has a new show and I
was invited on to that program I told
you last week how I was offered a whole
bunch of money to be on that program
others have reported including Sam cedar
being offered $5,000 to appear on Gavin
McInnes program which is a paywall
program meaning you only can see the
content if you become a paid subscriber
my manager actually did some negotiation
with the Gavin McInnes team which may
have been actually just Gavin McInnes
communicating with my manager under a
different name and was able to actually
negotiate a pretty substantial rate and
in the midst of this negotiation that
was going on I received a phone call
from a guy named Jim telling me that I
should appear on Gavin McInnes show who
we later determined with like 99.9%
certainty was actually Gavin McInnes
himself here's a reminder about that
okay
let's go next to our caller from the
two-five three area code who's calling
today from 253 hey David it's Jim and I
just wanted to say a longtime listener
first-time caller loved ya and I just
wanted to talked about the green new
deal and just see what ideas you had
about maybe getting that pushed through
and also a guy I despise came up on my
YouTube the other day on the commercial
Gavin McInnes on this new show free
speech and I was trying to click out of
it
right away and then all sudden I saw dr.
Cornel West and Mark Lamont Hill on the
show yeah and I actually checked it out
and it's a cool show in regards to just
liberals nailing Gavin and it was so
awesome watch especially Mark Lamont
Hill I cancelled my subscription because
I saw all the shows but I just thought
it'd be awesome if you could get on his
show and destroy
so hold on cancel your subscription to
what oh I signed up just to watch the
Doctor Who am on Hill oh I see any
Cornel West sure so then Sam cedar from
the majority report later did a segment
explaining that he also had been invited
to appear on Gavin McInnes program he
also talked about this call I received
from quote Jim who appears to really
have been Gavin himself Ana Kasparian
from The Young Turks was also invited
she did a segment about it in the last
day or two and covered that as well as a
Sam and I being invited on to the
program to appear with Gavin McInnes and
now hilariously Gavin himself has done
an entire episode attacking us because
despite the offer of money we have at
least so far refused to appear on his
program which is hilarious because if we
will only so if we get invited with note
with no money being on the table and we
refuse to appear we are not willing to
engage with the other side or whatever
if we are offered money and appear then
it's well we're only appearing because
we were given money not because we
actually want to engage with the other
side if we turn down the appearance
despite the offer of thousands and
thousands of dollars to appear then all
of a sudden the problem is that we are
just not willing to engage with the
other side even though you would think
that it would be a sign of sort of the
the the the fact that we are not going
to be tainted or influenced by the money
alone we are going to actually make
decisions about what appearances do and
don't make sense so check this out this
is a tweeted screenshot promoting this
event where Gavin says this episode this
entire episode is dedicated to ana
kasparian sam cedar and david pakman who
appear to be outraged that gavin offered
the money to debate a conservative why
is it so hard to get liberal guests why
do they consistently refused to compete
in the marketplace of ideas and
people actually wrote to me and they
said David you really should address
this like why not just appear and
compete in the marketplace of ideas with
Gavin what's important for you to
understand is that the pitch was not
debate Gavin McInnes about this topic or
that topic or the corrosive nature of
his influence on the political discourse
the invitation was show up and have
Gavin McInnes play talk show host and
moderate a discussion between David
Pakman and some conservative Sam cedar
and some conservative ana kasparian and
some conservative and the the problem I
have with this and I've talked to Sam
about this as well
is that I feel as though I'm
contributing to the whitewashing of
Gavin McInnes in a way that I was not
immediately comfortable with and to be
clear I have not actually turned this
down the reality is I can't go to New
York City and do this until the fall
anyway I'm traveling every single week
between now and Labor Day and we have
the David Pakman show summer vacation
coming up for which I'll be out of the
country so we basically just tabled it
he I guess interpreted it as I'm turning
down the appearance I'm open in
principle to appearing on Gavin McInnes
program but what I feel is the real
problem here is that number one again by
allowing him to play talk show host and
moderate a discussion between another
conservative and me I'm sort of
whitewashing McInnis and again these are
videos that would be pay wold just for
his paid audience the last thing I want
to do is give this guy paid subscribers
by allowing him to promote an appearance
that I did with someone else that
contributes to the whitewashing of Gavin
McInnes and may actually get people to
sign up and pay for his program now I'm
curious
I haven't again because the show is pay
walled I have no idea what was actually
said during this episode I'm curious
whether he addresses the fact that he
called into my show pretending to be a
guy named Jim suggesting that I should
really as a leftist go and appear on
Gavin McInnes is program I don't know if
somebody has a subscription to his
program maybe they can tell me if that
comes up my guess is
does not come up